yeah hello to you this happened around
an hour and a half ago there was an air
raid siren uh and reports of jets flying
overhead and then reports of three loud
explosions followed by
uh this large fire which uh you can
probably make out behind me this huge
black plume of smoke which is filling
the air in this uh area of lev now we
went down to the area as close as you
could get
to the fire there were police emergency
services soldiers moving everyone away
we saw a number of people arrested for
uh taking pictures and for reasons we
don't yet know
uh but certainly that is the scene here
in levith at the moment
following the sound of three loud
explosions this afternoon uh now we have
had it confirmed from lev's governor
that two missiles uh hit the city
the mayor has called it an attack on the
city uh and preliminary reports suggest
that five people
uh have been injured now there's also
concern that there could be a secondary
attack so the advice remains uh to stay
indoors for all those uh residents and
civilians but that hasn't stopped so
many people in that area down there it
there are a number of apartment blocks
uh around this in the vicinity of the
fire and lots of people out having a
look at what's
happening
many very emotional some people quite
angry and and and there are high
emotions certainly
and let me just uh show you over here to
the right
a frame you may be able to make out
there's a communications
tower and early reports suggest that
that was perhaps uh the target
and instead
the strike was actually what it actually
hit was an oil depot as we understand at
the moment the fire is very large we can
see flames from here as well as
obviously that huge cloud of smoke and
the concern is that there has been
there have been high winds this
afternoon so of course they are
concerned that that could spread there
are a couple of petrol stations next to
the fire as well as of course all those
residential buildings
as well this is the third strike
in this area of the country this month
uh there was one on the 18th of march uh
at an aircraft repair facility next to
the airport around five miles from
outside outside uh lev city center
and then another uh airstrike on a
military training base where western
volunteers were being trained uh beyond
lev much closer towards the polish
border only around 15 miles from the
polish border and certainly uh there's
some commentary here today to suggest
that this is no coincidence that this
strike on la viv which has been very
much a safe haven for so many ukrainians
uh fleeing fighting uh in the last four
weeks of war that this is a message to
president biden of course who is in
warsaw just over the border in poland
meeting his counterpart today and of
course he met members of the u.s
military who are based over in poland
yesterday he's also been meeting
refugees some say this is no coincidence
that this attack on lev has taken place
today while joe biden the president of
the united states is in the region but
certainly for all those
thousands and thousands of ukrainians
and and families who've fled to lev for
safety this will be very very unsettling
news indeed